welcome to this video playing zoo ball
so for Ross so for rosine not and not do
that Disney from Belgium Stefan zorz
yeah this is a belgian i am the toffee
and shadow hmm what am I doing here
actually hmm I normally have to be three
already plating okay I was simply
forgetting forgetting my maligns him
okay this is also a way to play i think
i'm not sure if this is the main line or
anything push up to age three i think
this is how they play it I never really
understood why or how or whatever
whatever but this is kind of the way
this opening is played nowadays g500 me
and the six was hanging could have taken
this pawn very much possible I guess I
should have taken the move the bone okay
night efore here maybe a Bishop f4
and what are we at what a weird position
yeah really don't know not sure if g5 if
this is what what black ones ok I can
take the six or not is there a big big
technical idea Knight e5 at the end
maybe both hmm maybe but ok I had some I
had a tech d6 so i might as well take it
if he if he lets it go oh wow not to
move I expected
hmm
okay my queen is also attacked him they
can take with the rook 26 but I don't
really have a grain move after that came
probably this one what about see 5 vs c5
c6 okay I guess that's the only way to
make some sense of what I did before we
see six maybe following
when you read game but it happens if you
play complicated line that you
absolutely don't know
after Quincy seven my dear what's the
place is six of course and I'm wondering
if this is really really working as long
think irritates me a bit I really don't
see an alternative maybe 25 but night I
Bishop g2 intending 91 looks looks a
problematic Quincy seven looks normal c6
takes Knight d4 you can take on d4 with
the bishop not clear to me not
absolutely not but I don't see Quincy 7c
success losing or anything okay if I
don't play c6 this this didn't really
make much sense I guess hmm or is there
something entirely entirely different
available well I don't see it the SIS
must must be the way to go at least I'm
getting the great dark squared Bishop an
hmm
of course you always want green age 72
work in queer rook h3 made or something
that would be that would be very cute
probably not going to happen though he's
got five coming Queen d5 also
quindi 5 m-f three probably ugly ugly
chest is going into a self pin here with
Bishop g2 and not sure how bad it is
though 25 morning I guess threatening
made probably forcing the trade and then
he's really in the spin
and how does he defend this he's got
he's got 98 I'm such an idiot we should
be too i saw was winning yeah i
absolutely saw this and I still are
meant for this nonsense no this is just
this is just idiotic yeah one of those
games where I really should be shot for
what I did oh man this is this is
totally annoying it was a it was a total
win simply maybe I should have played it
for me at name
yeah i'm not sure what to make of this
King b5 I don't have eight I don't have
my age 5 or anything check
the sea has the check maybe the scent e5
it's not to break through the lab I'm
screwing the Sun check check check check
mate oh wow well what did game poo wow
this was this was a close call at the
end Wow yeah but I'm a total idiot yeah
absolutely here I was thinking okay well
Bishop b2 is fantastic yeah let's play
that and then i thought i would see six
wins apiece right and then at the end
that viader terrible i can just go to be
to end this thing is just gone yeah I
saw that but I thought this is simpler
why not take the piece his problem is no
move he's now pinche on c6 and night be
aight i just take e 5 and he resigns
this thing totally totally stupid Luke
c6 and I why don't I take here actually
this is still a simple win yeah I was so
angry this is still a very simple win if
white gets get this one I have an extra
poor Nia yeah well the bill before it
was certainly good I think it should be
good for black problem we had this weird
thing then I played see 525 seems to be
better okay but I'm interested in this
position Casey six takes Knight takes
Queen takes
with some advantage too wide okay Oh
difficult where I see that I maybe have
some compensation but computer is
introduced to sing suggestion rook c8
computer once play this let's totally
inhuman this is kind of line looks like
black-ish is giving up piece but he has
chances to get it back of course I have
talked about a weird line hmm okay after
this black is black is better shouldn't
you two with a pin and now e5 seems to
be right and the Queen d4 is just
winning outright yeah yeah I had this
feeling but as I was just super just
Bishop b2 this is this is just a stupid
I saw it when it wins but I know Roxy 6
okay well okay well thanks for watching